hello today it's a french
guy i'm going to interview adrien jourdain who
lives in estonia and one
bleeds english through the
internet so he's a language entrepreneur
as i say before hello adrien
hello when they  make an enemy thank you
for having me here sorry it's english
that comes naturally it doesn't
matter that's what's interesting
if you see here i'm i in tallinn in
estonia and most of the people who have
between to simplify in 20 and 40 years we
spoke English fluently
it was extremely interesting
because it is in their daily life so
can I ask a good
taste before entering the question of the
languages ​​of English then  absolutely
through the internet
why do you live in italy
so i stayed in france for a
long time i had the opportunity i
traveled before i lived 2 in germany 2
or 3 years in russia
there i am in  tallinn for now for
the summer and i will no doubt  and stay there for the
long term because I am
deeply European here they are but there
is a difference between being European if
you want on paper to say that it is
good and the freedom of agreement that is the
first thing is obviously that that
goes through languages ​​and it's an
ideal country because for us French it's
easy to settle down I can practice
Russian every day yes just plain old
I went to buy a jar
of honey
you know  all now dear friends
but I do them in Russian I can
learn a language that I don't know
at all which is very very very
different from a root point of view
it's Estonian so even learning a
few words I can't practice it
English I can live in a country which
is extremely democratic in which there is a
lot of interest and which is very
specialized in two sectors that are close to my
heart, digital technology and education
and when I saw sharp it is really
the top  from the top is what is
the  'Estonian it seems to gather a
little in Finnish if I understand then
it is very close to Finnish and if you
want the legend rats which is
closest to Estonian it would be
Finnish it would be we will say the cousin
it's not even the first so it's
us cousin even before he doesn't get along
between the ass is not understandable
well no then an Estonian will not
understand someone who speaks in
Finnish but on the other hand there are a lot
of people  which look alike we feel that
it's a language which is still
quite close but a bit like
Romanian and French oh well if
I hope I'm not talking nonsense
but it's still hard for a French speaker
to understand the  Romanian orally the same
but it's still from London the team
here are who are distant I thought the
two were really distant in the family
of Latin languages ​​and then you have
Hungarian which is related but which is
still very different that's a
lot  further and after you have
dialects  you speak in russia the same
language the same family but that's all
so here are the streets if you speak russian you
were in germany only by german was
able to get by in german i'm
doing better than in russian but in a
hive can  have a fairly
classic version and in German I understand
all the little subtleties of the
taxi driver here and and and who
teaches English through the internet
is that what it is that you did
the same thing the russian way  so
in fact I have always used the
internet to help French speakers
it is very important because I think that
we will leave newport French
speaking English as we could inform
Russians, for example, that has nothing to do
because the mother tongue  is not
the same so it changes a lot of
things so I am really in
English for French speakers there is a
lot of debate and rank because we
are not very good and I have always
done them in fact on the internet in  I didn't
I haven't said it here I'm
in russia so I'm going to do it like that
and I'm in france I'm going to do it
like that I'm in estonia I'm going to
do it like that it's not much changed for
even in fact  but the fact for example
I watched some of your
videos
the fact of being in tallinn it makes it all
interesting what it's a certain thing that's so it's traveling around
europe
in the world
teaching english  to present this
to people all this
makes learning more interesting all the
time and that's why once a
year in fact I go on a big trip where I
ask my audience I select
English-speaking countries and I  tell them
here is where would you like
you would like sorry that I go
so I went to new york
two years ago to sign last year this
year it's a little bit more complicated
of course so beats  aline it was possible
so we take advantage of it but I really like it
as you say you are right b  well
obviously but from the context in fact yes
that's it that's it you have to know how to
use the internet tool because
it's not it's not classrooms
what people you what are the
differences what are the can  -be
from the disadvantages where the advantages of
this kind of teaching
or explanation of languages
what the work you do in
relation to what does and the teacher
a sad tutu a bag in the face of bombing
gaza classes traffic  common sense is
technical but we are moving from a
vertical distribution, that is to say where
you reach a small group of people
because you are physically limited to
something horizontally so me
for example the youtube channel hyves xbox
poker
it is  watched by 6 7 thousand to 15000
unique people per day
I could never have touched so many
people besides I will put the link
in the description January 7 to you
thank you yes and you have the possibility of
any person in fact of the
moment  Or  you have this desire in fact
to teach to transmit your pleasure
to people and it is not because it is
through a screen that people
feel it, on the contrary people
will easily identify with you with
your values ​​it  you have to feel your
personality and suddenly thanks to that you
can really have a real community
which creates emulation and which
creates social ties and that's
totally counter-intuitive because we
tend to think that in fact
that the internet will destroy their social relationships it's totally wrong the internet in my opinion
it's neutral by nature and it all depends on
how we use it and I think me
for example you have me I've been putting a video
a day for almost three years  wow
so i'm a big job i'm trying
soon there for example you see there yesterday
i worked with a language school
in tallinn who actually got me who
rents me their premises on sundays and they have
a great
board  interactive so I asked
my audie  nce I made a video here is
testing I could be fao
the lessons like that what is it
you in france and it is so you have a
big enough the third point to a
big reactivity in fact because  you
see right away people tell you
yes no and as you have less status
or hierarchical relationship students teachers
that I don't really like suddenly people
will say straight away it's good it's not
good especially in a  French-speaking domain
in a
French-speaking cultural environment where we still have a very high
social status, we the
French, you the Anglo-Saxons, they
are Canadians, Americans, English,
British, Australian, etc.,
you have a more direct relationship, you
see, we have less of that, so that allows
a bit of damage and that puts the case on these
two sides on the positive side in fact
while Quebecers and
Quebecers are rather like like the
others so let's say no no no not at
all not at all it's very real name
anna  it's unique it's liège in europe
finally having all that either the
french by the spanish but
speaking the germans the french are a
little more formal let's say yeah yeah yeah
but that's not bad either
it's the charm  also but in fact it's
very interesting the links the links that
link to between for example you who
make videos but every day people are
starting to know you and I too
am making videos people are starting to
know me if ever I  meet
someone in an airport
it's you it's steve bruce thorgal and
i think that at this death a
different relationship from what one could have
with a teacher
the teacher and sometimes it can be
closer more  closer more alive as
completely and there is another
thing too which is quite stupid but
which we don't think of because kif
also hides behind this kind of
relationship is rare chic which sometimes
can be harmful is that  the fact
we have  don't tend to have the student
come to such a place at such a time
you look you go there when you want to
learn and when you are ready and that
's a huge benefit for people
who after and after you can also choose
depending on your level and I
wonder now with the co life
must finally be
distance learning a lot a lot
gained momentum because of that the fact that we
can't go to classes and then
now will come back  to the
situation before there is more more traditional formal
but will there not be
things that will really
fundamentally change that we will see that
not only for the Olympics but for
many in many
situations teaching  remotely through the
internet to others has advantages for
the for the teacher for the student that
here we are not going to return to the
situation before do you think three
points three points me I see three
not here already that  depends on the country by
example you see here in estonia they
all switched to distance learning in a very short
time they are
so good in digital
I sincerely think that maybe with
singapore which must be roughly at the
same level maybe a little bit earlier
who hang behind I don't know but
it's really in the top 3 countries in the
world and it's a small country so we do
n't pay much attention to it it's
culturally quite introverted people so
it doesn't show much better  for example
could see that not change much because
they were already good he had
the infrastructure and they put the
whole school at a distance and I speak for
primary schools so really
for children teenagers ok so
for  sands and it's still the case
now
because they reading we like to
control their coheed problems
do the children go to school there or
not so it's summer in
the northern hemisphere europe  it's summer they
will resume at  month of September but
they have already prepared the plan in case
if it starts again it switches everything to
town hall so for them it hasn't changed
much
after you have the more
French version where you even had
administration who said we  will
help people to train in English oh yes
but six months a year ago it was
we do not accept training that is
only online online sorry I
do Franglais sorry professional training
and suddenly well no
c  It's not possible, for example, when you
lose your jobs in France and you
said good, well, that's the time
I reformed my English to have
more skills and find a job
in design. Iain has to
go face-to-face.  with the co by death
changed because in fact people didn't
have the choice and maybe the people
who also decide various
levels realized that in fact the fact that
it was online was absolutely not
harmful  so there was none  a concern
but that's the situation that made
his strength and so that for once it
will never be like before and after the
third point is that you have an
acceleration in fact it gave a
kind of really a  like a bit like
a catapult you see you hold back and
suddenly you let go and accelerate
tremendously the number of people who are
going to take training on the internet
in fact it's a bit or if we had
gained five years  quite simply
yes of course so that was my
complete answer and that's it bah it's very
interesting it was that's a game we
can discuss it for hours but as soon as
we go there we will finish it but
thank you very much it's  very interesting the
fact that good you are multilingual you travel
and you live in this country which is very
advanced for a
digital purpose you teach through the internet
so we were able to discuss things in
French and what is good for the
legs of my channel which  is studying
French is by the way we are going to m  be
this discussion in squarely in
the ic as are but it has been very
interesting one of the ideas very very
interesting and well thank you very much
ab the pleasure since giant that I am
very honored and helped and I drag myself
as I say I will put the  link so
that listeners can visit your channel
and after and see a little late leigh but
that's all
ok thank you very much thank you steam see you soon
goodbye see you soon see
you soon
[Music]